saint
yeah he can do that oh wait wait wait
wait whoa we got a character and stevia
he does
this is actually legit pocket character
he he has played i remember quite a bit
right and uh
yeah so this is interesting i mean i
mean noctis has like crazy you know
rule-breaking range right in uh in
tekken with some of these attacks
and uh maybe he feels that he can just
outrange uh
and frustrate saint here
fight
yeah let's see how it goes you're the
knock this pick coming out of cbm here
oh
yeah
face dab
yeah i thought imagine obamacare i just
wonder i imagine it like in the final
fantasy like move name was you know like
what's happening
yeah there's another one again there's
another face tab there
ow
yeah that counter hit though
that was good
oh
i definitely think cherry berryman goes
to this character because he feels
confident about this matchup but he is
at the wall now
trying to get out
oh yes
anytime you see the downforce beat come
out you know saints getting in the group
yeah yeah
man this looks really annoying to deal
with the four four one plus two
this is very interesting
yeah now what do we expect it right
a lot of damages
can't load period either so that's uh
that's an interesting
strategy here because you know it stands
this guy who likes back dash and like
swift punch you uh what do you do about
those downstairs yeah
nicely done
round four
fight
cool i thought it was gonna be counter
hinge
yeah what
[Music]
oh nice sedation on that uh projectile
yes cherry berry mango i think he's
trying to
kind of keep him out but saint has still
been able to get in
and start his mix-ups
yeah
not this time
oh okay nice block here
oh just out of range i feel like
yeah
i can't believe we even got the clap
after that he's down to whip and he got
the four forward clap on it very hard to
do saint
solid first game the the knock stick
looked kind of interesting at first but
i don't think so
yeah yeah i mean he got he got a couple
of space tabs uh of course counting
couple based out he's got stuff
yeah i think he just wanted to kind of
take advantage of his range but just it
didn't happen he just got in and did
down down four threes and down four twos
and you know got stuff going anyways so
i don't know if he's gonna stick with
this this character
yeah and like i was mentioning it's only
first to two here this is losing
semi-files this is not the loser final
of the tournament right so uh picking
out you know pocket character choice
like this like you gotta have a pretty
good just uh reason for that right like
your decision making on that has to be
on point and uh it look it looked like
it wasn't a terrible choice at first but
uh overall it doesn't work out so now
he's in a a little bit of a pickle right
he's either committed to knock this the
whole way or he's gonna have to switch
over to the gin uh and that's the reason
that i don't like playing multiple
characters in tournament you know i just
want to stick to the one and know what
i'm dealing with you know you have to
second guess yourself between matches
you don't got to rethink strategies
halfway through you're just sticking for
him like all the way through so
let's see what he decided
all right
all right he's sticking with it yeah
yeah
oh yeah he got uh he got his stage
here
uh
yeah
match the character to the stage i'd
like probably give you some kind of buff
right i don't know
you would hope so
taking them home
yeah a lot of gays players do choose
howard state here we go
this is a game two saint up one game
best of three
[Music]
with that counter hit
oh no downpour one for you i'm gonna be
out of range yeah exactly that's the
thing already
same is so good at judging your
character's range look at this
yeah that was so successful
oh that's the second time he's done that
yeah
side switch
like no no no
[Music]
right now stay down
the weapons are coming
out yeah
he's not [ __ ] after once
oh i think that's the first time we saw
that
very linear move
[Music]
boy if he had punished that right there
he could have backed that down for two
caught him stepping ooh
another down two could close it out here
mix up with four four that was two maybe
slightly out of range
oh my god no throw break oh
yeah so strong this tournament oh
headbutt nice very fast move
oh here we go
there's that counter hit that i was
looking for
check how to get in oh
that was weird
yeah okay guess the wall splat here
oh the pickup
the same
range if he can survive
oh
he was like backwards dude what
yeah that was his nose cherry brain
mango recognized the situation that was
very smart with him right there yeah but
overall
uh oh my goodness the throws that was
crazy
look at the damage oh my god
oh my god
see you later with the perfect that was
perfect that was perfect saint
yeah just continuing his his streak
right now he's just been
yeah he's
been on a tear
uh he's been so successful with his uh
his downforce twos everything working